bonjour bassem alors manifestement
l'appel a été entendu
effectivement l'appel a été entendu son
coucou à s'être donné rendez vous sur la
place de la république pour cette marche
est pour le mieux
la marche est contre la loi qui a été
votée nous
dans beaucoup d'associations
d'organisations de politique mais
également d'entreprises se sont donnés
rendez vous ici sous le soleil de paris
et 7 le plutôt rare en ce moment quand
est ce qu a débuté il ya un peu plus
d'une heure fêté sur la place de la
république et qui causent de diriger
direction la place de la bastille quand
vous pouvez voir une ambiance plutôt bon
enfant la police quadrille le périmètre
mais qui ne sont pas visibles pour
parents on peut voir dans plusieurs
manifestations
on a pu discuter avec certains de ces
manifestants je vous propose d'écouter
parce que vos prochains le climat c'est
qu'il ya 149 mesures qui ont été faites
trois qui ont été retirés par macron
d'office et ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il ya
à peine 10 % des promesses qui vont être
passées du coup on est en dessous des
ambitions prises par le gouvernement et
quand on sait que le réchauffement
climatique c'est une menace estime pour
l'avenir de l'humanité
je pense que ça exige beaucoup plus que
des petites mesures et je pense qu'il
est important que la jeunesse et toutes
les personnes aussi concernées puissent
aussi montrer qu'il ya encore du monde
sur le combat écologique
malgré tous les problèmes qu'il ya en ce
moment sanitaire écologique c'est
toujours important de se rassembler et
de montrer que le climat c'est pas
quelque chose danek ce qu'on peut voilà
sous prétexte qu'il ya d'autres
problèmes très importants
c'est pas quelque chose qu'il faut
oublier et je pense qu'il faut se
mobiliser pour l'heure on a le sentiment
que là il va vraiment falloir passer à
des réglementations
et un système et enfin voila il va
falloir obliger les gouvernements à
prendre des mesures légales pour
permettre qu'on avance et qu'on sorte de
ce cette masse et bon voilà on se
faisait la réflexion que on était très
peu nombreux que les crs ne sont pas là
pour nous taper dessus c'est une bonne
nouvelle ça veut dire aussi que tout le
monde s'en fout en fait et ça c'est très
préoccupant
il ya cette loi qui est passé dont on
sait qu'elle est insuffisante
quelle est en grande partie hypocrite
qu'elle est en grande partie si je puis
dire
instrumentalisés et voilà il faut être
là il faut être là il ya des y avait de
nombreux combats en ce moment a amené on
peut pas les mener tous
non c'est bien qu' il n'y a pas de plan
b pour la planète vous l'aurez compris à
venir à une convergence des luttes pour
tous ces manifestants venus défendre le
climat est venue interpeller le
gouvernement qu'ils jugent irresponsable
dont les mesures ne sont pas suffisantes
pour lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique comme vous pouvez voir la
marche a commencé elle continue une
ambiance plutôt bon enfant beaucoup de
fanfares se sont donné rendez-vous pour
accompagner ce cortège sous le soleil
parisien qui est en train de se diriger
progressivement et doucement vers la
place de la bastille merci bassin pour
toutes ces précisions se retrouve tout à
l'heure